an alarm call for russia sunday marked
the fourth recorded single day increase
of coronavirus cases and the worry now
is what lies ahead and how russia's
strained health care system will handle
it
medics complain of shortages of
protective equipment and testing
capabilities and the high rate of
hospital workers who've died from the
virus
Russia's reported death toll remains
relatively lower than other countries
but it has doubled the number of new
cases it had two weeks ago authorities
say that is because of increased
screening the spread of the virus is
mainly caused by those who have it
without symptoms so it's good when the
infection is detected at an early stage
infection number is rising but not the
spread of the illness itself in Italy
1000 newly recruited health workers
prepared to assist doctors and nurses
working inside the overcrowded prison
network detention centres there have
been at the heart of the coronavirus
crisis from the very beginning and the
fear is that it could prove to be a hub
for renewed infections this as the
leader of the Roman Catholic Church used
his Sunday address to call for
international cooperation to combat the
pandemic important in 40 maintenance eme
it is important to unite scientific
capabilities in a transparent and
impartial way to find vaccines and
treatments and to guarantee universal
access to essential technologies that
allow each infected person in every part
of the world to receive the necessary
medical treatment France is now
preparing to enter its final week of
strict confinement measures its Health
Ministry announced that the number of
people who have died from covert 19 rose
by a hundred and sixty-six to more than
24 thousand seven hundred on Saturday
while figures for those admitted to
hospitals continued to decline it comes
with a warning from the Health Minister
if infections rise in the coming week
the lockdown could go on sonica llego al
Jazeera